[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
two
you jump in we'll talk about your
relationships your mental health your
job your career your money and your life
all right here on the ramsey show we do
it every day we talk about you right in
front of you it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
again dr john deloney best-selling
author brand new book in pre-sale right
now
own your past change your future you can
pick it up at ramseysolutions.com
dr john's new book is absolutely amazing
micah's going to start us off this hour
in philadelphia hi micah welcome to the
ramsey show
hey guys thanks so much for having me
sure what's up
hey so i'm just looking for a little bit
of financial advice here um
my wife and i we got married this past
may um we are both full-time and fully
employed or employed full-time so guess
what i'm trying to say we've got 135 000
left on our mortgage uh we have no other
debt or payments at this point i have
about i should say we have about 35 40
000 in liquid cash at this point not
including our emergency fund i'm just
wondering dave what do i do with it wow
way to go dude
you got to feel like you're on top of
the world
i do i don't it's weird in this in this
uh financial climate i'm yeah looking
for advice yeah
well we teach a thing that we believe
and have proven to be the shortest
distance between where you are and
becoming a millionaire becoming wealthy
and that is the baby steps process that
we've taught for years and baby step one
is a thousand dollars saved you've done
that twos you're dead free but the house
you've done that threes you've got your
emergency fund you've done that you
should now be putting away 15 percent of
your household income into retirement
out of your budget are you
yes sir yeah way to go more
yeah actually i uh we have 500
towards the roth ira each month
more than fifteen percent
uh i did not do the numbers i believe
that that's right around um that's on
top of our league chef uh 401ks as well
okay you need to add up what you're
putting into retirement it does not need
to be any more total than 15 of your
household income then you don't have
kids you just got married i assume right
that's correct yeah okay so baby step
five is kids college we can skip that
one for now
and baby step six is we put everything
else on the house until the house is
paid for so that means 35 000 is going
on your house today and if you back down
the
retirement to 15
probably more of your budget monthly can
go on your house as extra payments the
average millionaire that we have studied
in america pays off their home in seven
to 12 years we call them baby steps
millionaires because they followed these
baby steps how old are you
i'm 225 what's your household income
about 130. what's the balance on the
mortgage
135.
oh you're gonna have this house paid for
in five years four years i would love
that i would love less you're gonna have
a paid for house by the time you're 30
if you do what i'm talking about because
we threw 100 we just threw 35 at it that
leaves 100 you make 135 and so 20 000
bucks extra a year and you're going to
be done in five years you're gonna
you're gonna really be cooking man and
that's gonna put you in a position with
no house payment to save like a maniac
for retirement and wealth building and
you're going to become a millionaire
probably by the time you're
35. yeah and then you have kids you can
dump it into their college fund and be
done with that real quick easy
good for you guys college fund becomes a
wink and a nod at that point yeah
because you've gotten yourself so in
control and you're just ready to go cash
flow in college man what a great start
yeah that's pretty cool man
when you do it right and you when you're
when you it was modeled for you the
right way to do it and then two people
had that model and they come together
man now you're talking about you're not
changing family trees you're changing
family legacies at that point right this
is this kid's a legacy move yeah yeah
way to go dude very well done caleb's in
st louis hey caleb welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave and john i appreciate y'all
taking my phone call sure what's up um
i have a question um my father-in-law uh
whenever my wife was young
his company offered a stock option that
he could buy into for her
and then when we got married it became
ours
and it's grown it's about 16 000
now
and we're wondering is there any way to
put that into
some kind of child's
college saving fund or anything like
that for a without any tax implications
no
no cash it out pay the cash it out pay
the taxes they're not going to be much
yeah so what was it worth what was it
worth when she got it do you have any
idea
um well it's gone up uh these past
couple years um
you know by
60 70
cents um
and we have about 100
units to stop but i mean let's say 16
000 total dollars right
so let's say it was worth 10 000 when
she got it you're only going to pay
taxes on the gain over what it was worth
when she was when she got it
and the gain is at 15 and so if it's six
thousand dollars
six uh 15 is only 900 bucks
okay so you know you're not going to
have a big tax bill here
it's going to be a tax
one other follow-up question to that
then so if we would put that into a 529
or something
is that something we could use to pay
for our children's private education you
know why they're in grade school and
high school and stuff yes but i wouldn't
you wouldn't no i would save it for
college until you got college covered if
you've got more than you need for
college then yeah i might start doing
some uh some
uh
private schooling at that point but you
need to cover private schooling out of
your budget or not do it
okay
all right well i appreciate it guys sure
thanks for the call hey dave if you get
a lump sum like that they would have 15
grand to dump into the roth i mean to a
529. is there a cap on how much you can
roll into a 529 it's not a roll it's
just a price a purchase purchase depends
on the 529. some of them are up to 50
000. okay some of them are maxed at 10
000. is that annually or annually at a
time exactly uh and so
you know he if he got you know if he end
up with fifteen thousand bucks has two
kids you know he dropped 7 500 and he's
easily into two 529s for each kid and
you got a really good head start on
college at that point yeah okay so but
college would be
um
more important to pay cash for in a
student loan epic failure environment
than worrying about paying cash
if you don't you don't bleed your
college fund dry paying cash for private
school for
kindergarten right right and people do
that because there's very little data
that shows that where you went to
kindergarten causes you to succeed
very little data i mean but between the
extremes well especially the gap between
public and private school that well that
depends on the school system obviously
but i'm saying that the bottom end
versus the top end yeah there's a gap
but the whole the bell curve in the
middle not a lot of gap my wife reminds
me all the time that if you there's a
few things you do inside your home that
have much more predictive value on where
your kids how successful they are than
than the other
exactly very few pieces of data that say
you went to a 25 000 a year kindergarten
and that's why you're where you are
today if parents will read parents will
read to their kids and parents will
connect with their kids there's go the
long-term data there is much much more
predictive exactly
exactly
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
matt is with us in atlanta i'm matt
welcome to the ramsay show
hi david dr john
so basically my wife and i are about to
finish baby step three and also she's
pregnant
and i know that when people are in game
step two you say to pause pile up money
but i'm not sure about when
once you're in like four
should is that sort of advice no you
have an emergency fund
yeah so basically i um i have a twenty
thousand dollar check i'm waiting on
seven of that will be used to finish up
fully funding the emergency fund
and then i'm trying to figure out what
to do with the rest good for you cool is
this your first baby
yes awesome congrats man congrats do you
know what you're having actually
no no we don't oh that's cool if it's a
boy john or dave are great places to
start for names
his name is john so i i feel like that's
where you should probably david john
yeah
but anyway
uncle david so oh
there you go you never know
there's a chance so uh
yeah you just your emergency fund if it
is beefy enough that you have a comfort
level and your wife has a comfort level
if you're at the six months if you need
to be at the six-month side to feel
comfortable go ahead and take some of
the money and get to the six-month side
if the 7000 is only getting you to the
three-month side i don't care what you
do with it as far as that but fill that
emergency fund to where okay i'm a brand
new dad brand new mom first time i've
done this it's kind of exciting and
scary all at the same time and so i
really want to have enough
in my um
you know a big enough umbrella you know
in case it rains i i need a good
emergency fund and so whatever makes you
happy there whatever makes you feel
comfortable there is fine
but the um
then beyond that we're just going to
work the rest of the baby steps you need
to be setting up your budget
to begin to put 15 of your household
income into retirement
and
and if you want to use some of this uh
cash then
after the baby comes you can set it over
in a savings account and use it to open
a 529 after the baby comes and get the
social security number
right
and then more than what i'm is what i'm
wondering is
um
if i should use 12 000 of that to
fully fund a roth for my tax tax year
last year you know before that deadline
um just because i don't have a match so
roth is sort of you know my best bet as
far as it won't hurt you know won't hurt
anything if you want to do that that's
fine or you could set instead of setting
seven in the uh or you could do maybe
three things you could uh use some of it
to start the 529 and some of it to
funder roth hey matt are you expecting
any loss of income here
uh yes a little bit okay
you might want to cover that too yeah so
one of the things i'd recommend and if
you haven't already and we've talked
about on the show a million times
i'd sit down with your cash position and
see what it would look like to go sit
down with your um with the people who
are going to deliver your baby with the
hospital and come up with a a
pre-arranged price
a lot of ambiguity the reason you would
stack up cash because you don't know
what's coming and the more you can put a
pin to paper and say this is the amount
of money we're going to lose every month
while my wife takes time off or i take
time off this is the amount of money the
birth's going to cost it mean it gives
you a lot more peace as you're heading
into this new season of your life yeah
if you got it all detailed out but it's
beautiful that you have this check
coming and you're hitting this hitting
the stride all at this time so
here's the thing if it takes you three
months to uh implement all this after
the baby comes that's all fine and that
gives you some
you have a lot more knowledge about all
the uh variables by then than you have
today yeah there's nothing like uh
sticker shock of
diapers costs have i think they're laced
with gold are they they're so expensive
right they're a million dollars so i had
an idea i was way off so it took me a
couple of months to settle into this is
the new rhythm this is how much it's
going to cost to have this little human
in our house now
yeah it's it's that and that and the
formula stuff yeah oh man it's real
paul's with us paul's in san antonio
texas hey paul welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave how are you better than we
deserve what's up
oh well uh to start i found you guys by
accident scrolling about a month ago and
now i've turned into a daily listener
that's our best promotion
welcome to the game man
yeah well thank you um so
with everything since 2019
i personally i've done everything
backwards i went from being in a very
good position
and making plenty of money my income has
been cut by more than half after my
company folded i moved my my family to
texas so i could move you around because
i do construction
um unfortunately my wife cannot work
right now so we're a single income
family and i'm getting ready to start a
small business on the side
uh with things that i already own so i
can minimize the uh
the costs and you know they have to get
my licenses and my insurance and
everything
um
i make dirt for money right now at the
company i'm at and i'm wondering if
maybe i should just do the other job 100
just jump head in
or if i should just try to do it on
weekends for the time
uh what's dirt what do you make
i make 19 an hour
that's not dirt and how many are you
getting are you getting 40 hours
uh some weeks 40 some weeks i'll get
like 73
okay
all right so you're getting yeah you're
not that's not dirt i mean you're not
maybe making what you used to make but
that's not a yeah there's no shame in
that situation and that's a whole lot
more than zero
which is what you'll make if you don't
get jobs lined up in your new gig yeah
so yeah you work you work the side gig
as a weekend thing until you get some
real money coming in and a bunch of jobs
lined up and when you can get more jobs
lined up then you have time to do on the
weekend then we can talk about
backing down your hours or quitting the
day job but um you don't you don't jump
from uh hero to zero in any time anybody
has backed themselves into either this
answer or that answer i always wanted to
step back one more step
you could need to get another job for a
while and there may be another
construction company there in texas
that's going to pay you 24 an hour or 28
dollars an hour guarantee a time it may
be that there's an intermediate step and
i know you don't want to take a new job
because you're starting this new one you
hope this new one's gonna
take off but you may have to do that for
a season right yeah if it takes you six
months to a year to get your weekend
thing moving
then if you made 24 somewhere else
instead of 19 at this place but you're
not thrilled with this place
six times you mentioned that in the
early days of this conversation so uh
why and your wife working you said
um we're actually working with an
immigration lawyer she overstayed her
visa many years before i met her and
part of the part of that is uh she's not
allowed to work or it will automatically
fail her for overstaying or something
crazy like that okay so how long does
this take to get the immigration thing
cleaned up
um well i paid my deposit to my lawyer
in march and i have to come up with the
remainder it's another forty eight
hundred dollars to file the paperwork
and then wait for the courts
march is yesterday
a march a year ago last year yeah
so how long does this take
oh well they won't move forward with it
until i have my full payment and oh so
they're waiting for a year on you to
finish paying them
yeah well this is a priority that you
haven't made a priority
um yeah it's it's definitely a major one
um i've defaulted on a few things trying
to put some money away for it and
yeah how much is your truck payment
uh my check payment is 4.99 yeah sell
your truck
no
you're gonna lose you're gonna lose your
wife yeah sell your truck brother
and i do have my motorcycle up for sale
i own it free and clear good kind of
selling what will it sell for
uh i'm trying to get 9 500 for it good
that'll pay the lawyer do it yeah
motorcycle for spouse that's a good
trade every day of the week brother
yes
i'm most powerful
i can imagine her walking outside and
seeing that thing in the driveway for
the last year and this hasn't been paid
sell it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you got a bunch of other stuff
around your neck right now you need to
get off from around your neck called
debt
uh in order to get her immigration
straightened out so she can make money
and guess what you can make more money
and you don't need to be starting a
business with no income
while you've got all these other things
you're having to go into default on to
try to put stuff together so you need to
clean up a bunch of debt and uh you need
the extra income of the extra side
hustle plus your new job
plus your new job that john was talking
about where you make money so
and yeah you're probably selling the
truck it's on the motorcycle
get yourself out of debt moving in the
right direction hold on i'm gonna send
you a copy of the total money makeover
we'll show you how to do this brother
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well the new book john
is selling very well in pre-sale own
your past change your future it'll make
you laugh
cry i did both
and it'll challenge you for sure
when you take the steps outline you'll
take advantage of the free therapy that
is part of the
pre-purchase deal
you're set up to win and right now is a
really good time because people are kind
of uh
something about coming out the back side
of this pandemic stuff that has um
people are kind of had a existential
wake up that maybe shiny toys aren't
everything well you know the ramsay
millionaire study we did um we didn't do
a full study there but we've done a
small study just checking in with people
how are you doing
and it's overwhelming how how rough
people are doing out there mental health
is tough relationships are busted up
people are scared hurting it's it's
i knew it was rough i did not know it
was this rough yeah it's a tough season
for people out there
and you know the thing is the and these
aren't people that necessarily um
were
uh in a line around the block for
therapists
before yeah and but they were just going
okay there were some weaknesses in
my processes and my mental health i had
not dealt with some things and i was
getting away with that because
everything was going good yeah and then
when everything wasn't going good it
kind of brought everything boiling to
the surface and so we're getting people
the bad news is people are having to
deal with stuff that they should have
dealt with the good news is they're
having to deal with stuff they should
have done it's very similar to people
living their financial lives with no
margin we lived our lives with no
mental relational margin right we just
tolerated each other we were co-managers
of a house we weren't together well we
decided that facebook friends were real
friends and now you discovered they're
not and we ran from thing to thing to
thing to thing to thing we didn't have
deep discussions with each other so i
just assumed you believed everything i
believed and vice versa and then all of
a sudden man you rip that scab off well
you realize that maybe a tweet is really
not a discussion that's exactly right
maybe it's not a healthy
back and forth between someone you love
or i didn't
i didn't know you i didn't know you
thought that or believed that right it's
just been a great reveal
and um kind of like when you
owe a bunch of money you have a lot of
payments covered and then i'll tell you
lose your job it's been very much like
that yeah this has been revealing yeah
yeah
so if you can do one thing that would
make the time that you have even more
worthwhile when you do it
and you would of course you would we get
that
so here's the thing we're partnering
with better help we're going to give you
a month of free one-on-one weekly
therapy
when you pre-order a copy of the new
book
own your past
change your future
and um
this is a
going to be a number one best seller
we're we're selling them they're going
out the door like crazy
john's podcast is unbelievably popular
the dr john dolone show if you haven't
listened to it tune in
and so
get get this book on pre-order because
it's only 20 right now and you get a
free
month of one-on-one weekly therapy
and you get the e-book and you get the
audio book so it's quite a few hundred
dollars worth of stuff here for 20 bucks
and uh because we're really trying to
step into this
area where folks are struggling and give
you some solutions and they're all in
this package so get all of it at
ramseysolutions.com and let's get
started our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free you'll get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from gia in new york gia writes i
paid off my home got a raise and became
everyday millionaire last year
my wife and i lost our son in 2016 and
to get our mind off of him i started
working on investing and saving
my house is worth 650 000 and was paid
off in nine years we have four hundred
thousand dollars in investments thirty
thousand in college savings and thirty
thousand dollars cash savings
now i have zero drive and zero
motivation to show up at my hundred and
fifty thousand dollar a year job
every passion i've no longer ha
i've had no longer interests me
my plan for 2022 is to leave my job and
get a minimum wage job close to home
that i enjoy
my wife thinks i'm nuts what should i do
man um g if we were sitting here the
first thing i would do is get up out of
my chair and
give you a hug for about 30 seconds long
enough that it became uncomfortable for
both of us and then long enough that we
got through that and you had a chance to
breathe for the first time since 2016.
um anytime you try to skip grieving
and especially when you try to plug up
holes of grief with stuff or speed or
accomplishment
there's always a price to pay and it
sounds to me my brother like you are
completely and utterly
burnt out because you've been running
from your son you've been running from
dealing with that pain and um dave
that's a that's it's a common thing we i
don't know anybody that's never lost
somebody that tried to run and jump into
something else to stay busy and you know
come up with a new goal but the problem
is when you leave your 150 thousand
dollar job and go to your minimum wage
job you're gonna take you with you you
will go with you
and that pain and hurt will go with you
and it and you're just gonna add some
more pain and hurt that's right because
you're gonna
uh you're you you if you
go jimmy buffett on a sailboat for a
year
you're going to go with you you will be
on that boat that's right you're going
to go with you and so you you can't get
away from this so everybody in this
situation whether it happened a month
ago whether it happened you know how
long ago eight years ago
six years ago i want everybody in this
situation to
get by yourself all alone
and write your son a letter about how
much you miss him what the last few
years have been like
and sometimes that's a short letter
often the folks who have read them to me
in a counseling session or they've read
them to me um privately or talked
they're long and they a lot of stuff
comes up here and then i want you to
make a call to a counselor and go
because man there's a lot of pain here
and i'll tell you this on the other side
of this
there is a peace and healing that you
have not known for years and years and
years but usually it starts with that
first i haven't said this stuff out loud
it's been locked up in me for so long
i just want to talk to my son one more
time yeah and we're gonna start there
that one's hard
yeah
so
um yeah that's a step
you you need to
get in a situation in a group of people
um
[Music]
that you're not pretending with yeah
that you heard me grief demands a
witness yeah you gotta have people
around you yeah and and yeah you got to
sit down with somebody and you don't
need to quit your job no because your
job is not the problem right
and you're not going to get away from
this
um this feeling of i have zero driving
the other problem is this there's a high
incidence of a marriage loss with the
loss of a child that's right
and it's because people don't deal with
it right or they grieve differently one
says let's suck it up and get over it
the other well you know goes underwater
and becomes a millionaire right uh and
his wife and the wife standing by going
you're running so hard
away from everything
into something positive thank god he
wasn't doing cocaine with his level of
enthusiasm that's right that's right you
know but um
but you know it's all it's all
it's a it's a method of running and so
now you hit the wall that's right you
ran smack into the wall it bounced off
and now you're laying there going what
just happened i think i'll just go work
a minimum wage job that won't work zero
drive and zero interest zero
motivation that's depression right
that's what that is you run out of gas
that's right that's grief go deal with
it get in the middle of it you took all
the anger
from the loss
and you burned it all up doing stuff
yeah and you put a finish line for
yourself and you thought when i crossed
that line i'm gonna be free and well but
when the anger ran out the fuel was gone
that's right and now we're just sitting
here you crossed that line and there you
were and i'm just like what do i do now
yeah that's a part man i'm sorry it
breaks my heart it's a hard place to be
it's a horrible thing to go through i
can't imagine doing that
um but yeah uh congratulations on
winning on the money thing um but i'm
really sorry for how you got there and
the way it's worked out so yeah i would
what john said let's let's get into with
a therapist let's get a group of guys in
your corner start reading something
every day that makes you cry
talk to people everything yeah you
haven't cried enough yet
you probably cried a lot but you still
hadn't crowded enough
and
man
it's hard
it's hard
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america dr john
dolone ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
relationships mental health
careers jobs money it's all right here
on the ramsey show jackson's with us in
athens georgia hi jackson how are you
hey dave how are y'all doing better than
we deserve bro what's up
hey i just had a question about a
possible career change i have a good job
right now with pepsico running at the
delivery route
and i have no debt it's a 70k job and
i'm hesitant to do it but i have been
really looking into a program that south
georgia tech offers where you can become
a
dealer like a heavy equipment dealer
technician for caterpillar or john deere
and that's
that's the kind of work i really like
and
i'm kind of hesitant to drop this job
because it pays really well and i can
probably you know easily buy a house in
the near future if i just stick with it
and
do it but
i guess the work isn't
confused you said dealer and then you
said technician
are you going to become a diesel
mechanic
that's what i was looking at okay all
right so what's a dealer mean
uh like a caterpillar dealer i'll work
for work for like a caterpillar dealer
yes sir
okay okay yes yep okay what kind of
money sorry what kind of money will you
make when you're all
licensed up and you've got a full-time
job
well i'm sure well there's an internship
program so
i'm sure i would be very low maybe like
15 to 20 an hour starting out but
i've listened to some other guys who
have you know stuck with their companies
you know 10 years or so when they're
making what i make if not better
especially the field technicians and
that's probably what i would want to do
the guys who actually you know go out
and deliver stuff on the farm or not
deliver stuff but work on stuff
out in the field
i don't know i'm not sure about heavy
equipment and about tractors but diesel
mechanics in general it's not unusual to
hear somebody making six figures
right right so uh and i i don't know
where you're getting your information
about your low paid intern
uh because if you go through a
certificate program you shouldn't be in
an internship for very long or it'll be
part of your academic program
right well the internship would be
during school okay so like it's a
two-year program total but you will go
to school for like i believe it's three
months and then work for the dealer
between semesters
and dealers sponsoring you so they're
paying for your
school that's fantastic man and so look
at that not as
can you do that while you'd work
well well you would the campus is not
near me so
and so i would work for the dealer you
know of choice or essay of choice the
one that would sponsor me so i'd have to
find one to sponsor me first
but you have to quit your pepsi job to
do this right
yeah yeah the pepsi job is it's a it's a
lot of work okay so single you're single
and you make 70 and you're going to go
down to
35 or 40 for two years and get your
degree and then go up go up to 100 but
it's what you want to do
right that's the that's the path and
that's the question then yeah i would do
that all i i twice in my career i've
taken pay cuts to get to a place that i
wanted to go that ended up working out
and you want to make more at the end of
the story that's exactly right yeah but
you're you're making more at the end of
the story
right yeah so i i guess i just i don't
want to get into the field and then for
some reason i didn't look at all the i
guess
always
yeah yeah i guess that's true
true okay go do what you want to do
enjoy your life yeah but here's the
thing um i'm gonna i think you kind of
have looked at one possible way
one possible path
to accomplish the goal because the goal
is 10 years from today you're a
successful diesel mechanic making 100k
that's the goal right well
now how do we how we got there you found
one possible way that's a
company-sponsored thing the reason it's
company sponsored is they have a
shortage on mechanics and this is a way
for them to get mechanics it's a feeder
for their recruiting system
that's why this company is doing this
right and part of the deal
if you sign on to this is that you'll
work for that dealer that sponsors you
for x amount of years yeah i don't want
to do that i don't want to sign
something where i'm doing that for too
long look at that trade-off because that
might be
that may not be the best path to get to
10 years from now i'm a decent mechanic
making 100k you might be finding it at a
local community college for much cheaper
and then you got to go get your own work
which
clearly you're going to be able to find
the work
it's possible that you got community
colleges in georgia that are free right
or near free and you go over there and
you get your certificate uh nights and
weekends right and you keep the pepsi
job and then you're not beholden to
anyone and you walk out and you're
making 100k after two years not going
through all this stuff and you're not
handcuffed to somebody because they gave
you two dollars worth of tuition right
so you need to really look into that
part of it but the end goal is worth
looking at now what i want you to do is
i want you to have four different ways
you can get there right now you have one
and i'm not positive it's the best
because i don't know what the other
three are yet and neither do you and
when you can take all the variables all
the unknowns out of this by continuing
to research
then you're ready to pull the trigger on
which of the four options i'm making
this up that you're going to choose but
if you put four really strong reasonable
options in front of you two of them are
gonna suck and one of them two of them
are gonna be decent it's gonna be hard
to choose between two of them
and and then you're gonna you're gonna
find the right way to do this there's a
lot of ways to get at things there's a
lot of ways to open a a a subway
a sub sandwich restaurant a lot of
different ways to do it one is to buy a
franchise it's not the only way you can
do it right so there's a lot of ways to
get in that business you just got to
figure out how you're going to get there
and you don't have enough options yet
and you don't have enough information
yet but conceptually where you want to
go we're both on board and if the the
ultimate question is is it okay to take
a pretty significant pay cut to get
where i want to go
um and i've got a training i got
absolutely temporarily absolutely yeah
if where i want to go is more money
that's right and doing what i love there
you go but this idea that i have to
accept less money to be happy is
absolute hog boss incorrect and that's
not his question by the way all right
melissa is with us in salt lake city
utah hi melissa how are you
i'm good thanks for taking my call guys
sure what's up um
quick question i
married in my husband is amazing but his
family is a little bit
iffy when it comes to money
and so i was trying to talk with my
brother-in-law just a little bit because
they're in a rock and a hard spot
he has borrowed money
from another family member
and that other family member keeps on uh
changing the agreement changing
things up jerking him and his wife
around
and so i finally said you know what the
best plan might be to go take out an
actual loan
because the
loan people won't jerk you as round as
much as this family member is would that
sound advice to give them yes
okay melissa high five yourself you've
done good yeah yeah because here not
only are they getting jerked around and
not only is it a moving target and we
can't hit a moving target in this case
but uh thanksgiving dinner tastes
different
when you eat with your master and the
borrower is slave to the lender
and so when you sit down if your mom and
dad are the sweetest people in the world
but they loan you some money until you
pay them back that turkey tastes
different at thanksgiving
and it messes up your thanksgiving and
your kids thanksgiving and your
husband's thinking right it messes up
everything yeah and so
and and the thing is this um what what i
would do is add a little icing to this
advice
and uh
go ahead and whisper in both of their
ears like never do that again
okay like the one that made the loan and
the one that took the loan don't ever do
that again never do this with people
that you supposedly love
if you want to help a relative and you
have the money give them the money no
strings attached
or don't but don't loan them money
ever
and melissa the one other piece of
advice i tell you to pass along to your
brother-in-law sister-in-law is get this
final payoff from
your family member in writing
because you don't want to go to the bank
and take out a loan for seventeen
hundred dollars or ten thousand dollars
whatever this is and then a month later
i actually you owed me 11. or you owed
me 12 000. let's get it in writing let's
go to the bank get that number and get
it how much do i owe you if i wrote you
a check today that's right send me an
email with that yep it's all it needs to
be done that to be a contract just send
me an email telling me exactly how much
it is so i've got a copy and i can
remember what you said because i don't
want to forget what you said
and i don't want you to forget what
you're saying especially that's that
part of it there's that
oh that puts the sour of the ramsay show
in the books
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
best-selling author ramsey personality
dr john deloney host of the dr john
deloney show one of our more popular
podcasts on the ramsey network is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about relationships mental
health boundaries family careers jobs
and money it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five cassie is in chattanooga hi
cassie how are you
hey guys thanks for taking a call and
it's kathy k-a-t-h why oh i'm sorry i
misunderstood how can we help okay
well um
yeah a kind of unusual thing
maybe not but
probably the best way to call and i have
been signed up to join do the financial
peace university at my church and i
couldn't get off for work on the days
they were having it so
that was meant to be for me to get in
today okay i am 62 and a half i
work full-time and probably will be for
a while
um
my mortgage on my home
i only owe 14 000
great
yeah fourteen thousand dollars my house
is
yeah
it's a 1953 house do you have 14 000
i have more than fourteen thousand
dollars paid off today
i have a
mental
what i mean what do i do after i pay the
house off dance yeah do somersaults in
the neighborhood
cartwheels yeah yeah snow cone machine
it's a it's like a block it's like i i
have to have
something to pay on or you know i don't
know what to do
i don't know it's uh
because i love you kathy if you need to
send money somewhere you're welcome to
send it to me
so here's the thing you're right you do
need to do this and and what's happened
is you have lived using common sense
with a reasonably frugal situation and
have built a level of savings and have
avoided
normal levels of debt because you have
almost no debt and so just by using good
common sense what do you do for a living
i am a customer service agent for a
major
health care provider i help people that
have medicare
somewhere along the line your family
your dad your mom
something
that taught you common sense and you've
just lived well
now what we've got to do is we need to
add to the common sense one step
and that step is
intentionality because otherwise you're
going to feel like you're adrift which
is what you're calling about that
intentionality
is two things
one is you need a list of things that
you want to accomplish with money travel
generosity
a fun purchase
that's just for fun
more generosity
and more investing and you need a list
of these things say this is what i'm
going to do with money from this point
forward the second piece of that is you
need a written monthly budget which you
do not do yet
that causes you to put the money towards
that list
you have not won because of a written
budget you've won because of common
sense now i'm going to take the common
sense and stick that into a budget a
monthly rhythm that causes your bigger
goals to happen and i want you to set
some big
goals that are fun
and some of them will be for you some of
them will be for others and some of them
will just be to build some wealth it
could be simple as i want to have this
much money in a mutual fund it could
just be a target
of wealth and the wealth is to be used
i've got between 130 and 140 in
401k okay
well i would like for you to have 10
times that
i would like that too okay
there's a goal now you got a goal now
you got a payment to make only we're
making a payment to kathy no not to john
i guess
we're going to make john's not getting
this john's bahamas fund's going to
starve out here
but we're going to make the payment to
kathy and we're also going to do some
generosity what do you make of year
why run 34 gross way to go 34 to 45.
excellent okay so you're gonna do just
fine you've done great so far good yeah
and and now you don't have any payments
but here's the thing you've been making
everybody else rich with payments your
whole life
and now we're going to make you rich
but i like that this is the plan this is
the new plan see now we got something to
be excited about hang on we're going to
send you a copy the number one
bestseller baby steps millionaires it's
going to show you exactly how to take
baby steps to become a millionaire
because you're on baby step 7 you've
already done the baby steps but now
we're going to walk you up in and show
you the investing side and the wealth
building side and help you get there
like so many of people have done
following this stuff over the years
congratulations on being debt-free today
when you pay that thing off paid off the
house it's awesome neighbors near kathy
be forewarned cartwheels are coming
all right jenna is uh on the line in
orlando hi jenna how are you hey good
how are you guys better than we deserve
what's up
okay so i'm going to paint the picture
for you my husband is a police officer
making um between 40 000 to 50 000
depending on the extra details that he
works
a year
my sister and i own a company it's been
eight years
but
last year we decided to go in a
different direction with the company and
we opened up an online shop
and we're selling home goods
um
and so we have not generated a profit so
i'm not paying myself yet
and we did borrow some money um for the
company why um why have you not made a
profit
you should make a profit the first month
so
we have had months on november we
made a profit and then december did not
and then what are you spending the money
on
so we are spending we are paying three
thousand dollars a month on an ad
manager
and then it's not working
yes like so we're trying
we're trying to figure this out because
right that's the question it's like okay
why is it not converting um and what you
know didn't take me but one month to
figure out there's one guy this one sale
this guy has made you
mm-hmm he ain't making any sales
right
does he have anything to sell is your
product no he's a marketing
so our product is selling um but the
issue is so
obviously the supply chain right now is
messed up so our best sellers like as
soon as they sell out so if you put in
an ad it sells and then we don't have
enough inventory to
keep up with the demand and so then this
does not sound like a full-time job to
me i think you need to get a job yeah it
sounds like a hobby
okay so here's here's yeah okay so this
is kind of the question yeah my husband
so we're on a single income
um we have 21 000 in debt not including
the business debt
um how much business debt did you go in
so personally i owe 40 000 but if you
count on my sister's half because my
financial advisor said that i have to
basically take on like pretend that you
follow mine just because she ever walked
away um so 80 000
in
um
you spent 80 000 to open an online
business that's not profitable
what did you spend the money on oh my
gosh kiddo no
yeah this is now your side job your
part-time job you got a new job to pay
off your debt from the business failure
and
that's what you've got to do oh my
goodness i'm so sorry wow
[Music]
still on baby step number one how'd you
guess with health care costs rising
learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 825-5225
um
i uh we always pick on you right in
front of you but our last caller makes
me want to go back and revisit just some
concepts for a second not to pick on her
or her particular situation or her
family or whatever else okay
so a couple of uh principles
there
you do not borrow money
to start a business or to run a business
when you do you increase your chances of
failure
10x
80 of the small businesses fail in the
first five years the number one reason
for failure is described as cash flow
problems let me define that for you
having counseled small businesses for
two decades now
cash flow problems are
i took out a bunch of debt and can't pay
the payments while i'm trying to get
this thing up and running
because i'm not making a profit and i've
got to pay the bank whether make a
profit or not
cash flow problems are
we're so broke we're not making any
money we're selling some stuff and we're
not setting aside our sales tax and
sales tax comes due and we used what was
supposed to be sales tax money to send
to the state and we used it to stay open
and pay payroll
it's not illegal it's just dumb
and then you have a sales tax they have
the state revenue department around your
neck
uh cash flow problems are i'm not
setting money aside for the profits i'm
making for quarterly estimates for my
federal taxes and i get behind with the
irs you get behind with the revenue
department the irs and the bank you have
cash flow problems and this is what
causes small businesses to fail
right there
so you're not doing accounting and
you're going into debt
because everything in business has three
rules
it takes twice as long as you think it's
going to it costs twice as much as you
think it's going to and you're not the
exception those are the three rules
and
i have to live by those three rules and
so does everybody else and 90 of your
ideas suck
you're going to make all your money
and customer service on about 10 of your
ideas and you're going to conveniently
forget
all the dumb butt stuff you lost money
on to get there
you're going to repress those thoughts
dr john dolone
um but yeah i i can remember some of
them because i love telling funny
stories of my failures but i could write
an entire book and it would be very
thick on the dumbbell things we have
done at ramsey that have lost money and
the dave ramsey ideas have come in here
and i come in with a great idea and uh
man i had to learn to say never say god
told me because it makes god look stupid
when the idea sucks
it wasn't god right so god didn't tell
me this it was just dave on the running
trail it sounded great this morning when
my adrenaline was up but by the time we
went into actual application six weeks
later it was a really sucky idea and we
lost some money on it and i have done
that like i don't know 8 000 million
times and so this is what's going to
happen and then you end up the second
thing you don't do in business is you
don't go in business with partners
particularly your sister the third thing
you don't do is when you're a policeman
you don't allow your wife to do these
things or when you're a wife you don't
allow your dumb husband to do things
right we've taken calls where husbands
are eight hundred thousand dollars in
the hole to start the stream
this is not a 1940s leave it to be where
you're you have to ask your husband
permission that's not what i'm talking
about i'm talking about people that you
love you try to keep them from doing
dumb butt things that's right and it's
not a matter of if you're squashing my
dreams no i'm trying to protect
ourselves yeah i'm not a dream killer
i'm a nightmare killer
oh i like that dude i kill nightmares
all the time because that right there is
a nightmare that ain't a dream you know
that's what's gonna happen 40 000 bucks
a year and all of a sudden you look up
and you 100 grand household
that's i mean nightmare yeah and then
what that does inside your house is
you start hiding stuff you start getting
quiet you get you feel ashamed all the
time that impacts your marriage that
impacts your parenting and then all of a
sudden you're burning like the marriage
is on fire right what a mess and you're
not going to end up liking your sister
as much when this is done no hey let me
ask you this dave i've heard this a lot
from small businesses over the last year
is there some things people could do
about the supply chains i keep hearing
that and my default setting is that's
not an excuse playing better and i know
that's not fair and that's probably not
accurate
what are some things you can do
well some things you can't control okay
okay you're just screwed and it's just
gonna take some time okay
but what you have to do is you have to
say all right if you have to have a
contingency plan you can't just assume
stuff's going to show up when they said
it's going to show up because they'll
burn the boat down sink it to the bottom
of the atlantic with 400 cars on it or
whatever you know that thing that
happened the other day right so um
but i mean something sometimes things
happen we had a carton of stuff coming
from another country
on one of those ships that got hit by
the storms and it tilted and it dumped a
bunch of stuff into the ocean yeah guess
what our stuff was in the ocean floating
around so you know you can't you know
what do you you you know but the only
thing you can do is you can have a
contingency plan that says okay if that
stuff doesn't get here i'm going to have
it made stateside my margins are going
to drop way down but we're going to get
some product out and we've got a way to
get to market anyway at least as a
temporary measure we got a way to
continue to build this house as a
temporary measure we got a way to
deliver it may not be the exact thing
the same way we may have to change the
product line
but
you know but the other thing you can do
is you actually can go oh supply chain
sucks so we probably need to do some
planning we need to make sure they have
that we have more than four in the
warehouse before we run an ad campaign
that costs me more than the dead gum
items going to make me in profit because
we need to sell 4 000 to break even on
this marketing guy we're paying three
grand to
and we don't even have enough inventory
to do that well that's not good plan so
example of this is all right the john
deloney book
that we're doing
uh we have we bought the paper last
summer that's right
in anticipation of supply chain issues
and to get ready to launch a major
national bestseller in april
with john doloni we knew that this was
coming we bought the paper last summer
same thing with baby steps millionaires
so i'm not run out of baby steps
millionaires a friend of mine had a book
on the best seller list
the same week as baby steps millionaires
was number one
and they ran out of books
in january they still don't have paper
or books and the book was a bestseller
yeah and they missed the window yep
because they did not plan to have the
paper
last summer which is what you have to do
to get ahead of it now i mean stuff
could happen the paper could have got
dumped in the ocean with the ocean liner
going i mean i could have still messed
it up but you gotta do a lot of extra
planning i mean we're building the
events ramsey event center up here on
the hill and uh i was in a meeting this
morning with the building team the
construction crew and everything and you
know we're trying to anticipate okay we
got to have this fire pump
which has got a you know and it's got
like six valves on it and two
uh two chips chips are a problem right
and so you know when do we need it well
we don't need it until like august order
it now but it's no we already ordered it
but we're hoping it comes in this month
we're going to set it in the warehouse
five months ahead of time but then we're
not sitting around going we can't open
the building because we don't have the
fire approved you can't get the fire
department approval because we don't
have a fire pump so to run the sprinkler
system so that's just you know nine
million things like that in a building
what is there there's i don't know
uh thousands of those items that those
guys are having to manage supply chain
on right now and they're having to
double down on everything and so what
we're doing just buying it ahead and
stocking it buying ahead and stocking it
and that way the crew can keep working
that's right uh but if we haven't come
you know we have a labor problem that's
something we can't you can't stock that
one up that's right so you can't you
can't anticipate everything but you got
to think different and you got to think
ahead
and you got to get ahead of the curve
what you said was real important is
if you hire a marketing person or you're
selling burgers and you have a
restaurant with 12 seats
just do some napkin math and say how
many burgers can i actually sell with
only 12 seats in this little restaurant
here well i have enough to cover my
inventory if i have 3 000 bucks how many
of these products do i have to sell and
do i even have that many in the closet
in the back right that's just napkin
math that's not hard i mean there are
marketing consultants that are very very
good and worth every dollar
some of them are someone who got fired
from a marketing job and no one just
wants to work from home uh
and so in some
genres consultant means unemployed
you know and that's not always true of
every marketing consultant it's not
always true of all every consultant and
so i meet people all the time i've said
that for years their consultants like
you don't like us no i love consultants
i like the real ones but i don't like
the ones that don't have a job and so
they got business cards to say
consulting on them and then they cut you
know and the only sale the guys made was
her
you know that that's just that
i've had salesmen that worked here the
only sale they made was me to get me to
hire them and i had to undo that
decision
so this is this is business folks it's
boys and girls that's how it works this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
um
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225
cassie is in asheville north carolina
hi cassie welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you great what's up
um so okay i just started i just learned
about you at christmas time my aunt gave
me that wonderful christmas gift and
it's like some fat ugly socks right
[Laughter]
i am in baby step two now um i've been
super excited to start this process and
uh since listening to you i listen to
you all the time and i realize i have
been stupid
um i bought a brand new car last july
because my other car was getting a lot
of repairs and it's just getting to that
point
and i needed something reliable and of
course i thought the only thing i could
do was to buy a brand new car
well now i want to get rid of it
um
i owe 26 000 on it
and my car payments are ridiculous and
literally without this debt i would only
have four thousand about forty five
hundred dollars left in debt
um
the thing is is i
am a server in a restaurant i don't have
a whole lot of income and right now this
time of year it's really bad i'm also in
school so it's really hard for me to get
super intense and get extra jobs
because i'm putting my school first
right now tell me
okay and what would it sell for do you
have any idea
um well i have looked on like carvana
and stuff like that and the most i have
been offered is 25 000. if carbon offers
you 25 000 you can get 30. yep
i'm sorry i said if carvana offered you
25 000 you can get 30 for it
if you sell it privately okay yeah sell
it private because they're they're not
evil they're not a bad company but they
buy at wholesale in order to sell at
retail
and you can just sell it private sale
and make enough to get out of it and
have no debt and maybe enough to get you
a little two thousand dollar car or
something so go to facebook marketplace
someplace like that craigslist and see
if you can sell it there yeah jump on
kbb kellybluebook.com and see what
private sale appraisal is on your car
you'll enter a couple of facts about
your car
and it'll give you a number on what it's
what you can sell it as an individual
for and used cars are unusually first
time in
ever since cars have been made the used
cars have actually gone up in value
and this won't be a window that lasts
long so yes you need to get rid of it
you don't have
you're not making enough money to
justify owning a 30 000 car am i right
right
exactly yeah i mean i
like i said i'm a server so i don't have
stable income last year i made 34 000.
um well and the good news is servers are
engines the servers are in great demand
and if you're a great server you can
make really good money you work a lot
it's hard work
but um
but you can you can do really well and
you can control that the problem is
right now that this car owns you you
don't own it
exactly and i don't even like it
i mean i don't
i like how it looks i like how it looks
but i don't like anything else about it
and that's what i've learned that's what
my wife said we got married cassie
i'm sorry that's what my wife said when
we got married i like how he looks i
just don't like anything else about it
no sell that car sell that car and get
yourself a 2 000 car that you think
might die in the next few months it'll
get you to and from it'll get you out of
school and you will sleep like you
haven't slept in a long time yeah yeah
this is driving crazy this is stealing
your peace and not giving you peace how
old are you
uh we'll be 40 in april what are you
studying
um in med school from phlebotomy right
now
okay cool when will you graduate
may
okay good good so you'll be ready to go
get like a big girl job and stuff right
be poking people with needles and doing
all kind of fun stuff yes
oh yeah
and i mean it's really in demand right
now too
and i'm just i'm like so excited like i
want to get super intense when i'm done
graduated like i can work
maybe two three four jobs
and you know the other thing is you'll
be able to build up some cash when you
do that and buy a fifteen thousand
twenty thousand dollar car this time
next year for cash
right and that's what i was wondering
like i don't wanna stop on the baby
steps
but i didn't know if i should wait until
i'm done with school and well you need
to graduate from school your first goal
is eight your second goal is to graduate
from school your third goal is get out
of debt
right okay so as long as you're doing
those other two things and you got some
money then throw it at the debt
but
no we don't want to pay off debt and
then not have the money for school you
take out a big student loan or something
dumb like that
right finish school push on through you
got a good goal you're heading in the
right direction this car is a blocker
get rid of the blocker
okay yeah you're smart you got this
congratulations you're going to be well
on your way here sell this car well done
well done julio is with us in new york
city hi julio how are you hey how you
doing mr ramsay is a pleasure man you
too how can we help
um well i just had a like a question
about like
because
i'm like overwhelmed and deaf right now
man and i just don't know where to start
um i have two car payments because
you know i was originally my finance
you know the car started giving me some
issues um i started putting a lot of
money into the car and i started feeling
like it wasn't worth it man you know the
car was in 2012. i was still i still owe
money for the car i still do to this day
you know i was desperate for a car i
made it um
stupid decision
um so i got in this car
you know i had it like two years and
then i'm starting to give me an issue
with the transmission i started putting
too much money into it i said you know
what
i'm gonna just get a lease you know
because i travel a lot you know from new
york to pennsylvania back and forth so
i end up getting in the lease
and now now you're running up over your
miles now you're going to get hit again
man your cars are killing you
yeah the cars are killing me right now
you know i just don't know where to
start okay what do you make of here
uh i'll make about 50 000 a year right
now okay i think this job i just started
working on the warehouse okay first
thing is you suck at making car
decisions
so you need to say whatever decision i
make with a car i need to pay cash for
it from now on and i need to slow down
and quit you're keep you keep justifying
making these moves
with bad
uh
justification i mean you know if a car
breaks down it's not nearly as expensive
as paying car payments to fix it so fix
it
if a you know so the transmission every
time you have a little problem you jump
to another car instead of dealing with
the problem that's right in front of you
so this car that you got right now
you're going to drive it a while while
you get this mess cleaned up
um and then secondly we're going to get
you on a written game plan a written
budget
and we're uh we're going to set you up
with financial peace university to go
through the class and learn how to
handle money and plug you into every
dollar the written budget and you're
going to go get on that app and you're
going to make every single one of your
dollars behave are you married
i'm not yet okay cool how old are you
um 32 good and you make 50 grand
yes good
you have you got time to work some extra
oh well i jobs like do have um
you know a second job on the side of
work oh how much you make it
um i make about like
give or take like 250 a week
extra okay so you got another thousand
dollars another twelve thousand so that
puts you at 62. how much debt have you
got not counting this car
i'm not not counting the cars
um
i would say about like maybe 10 000
besides the cars okay so it's not much
that's good and yeah you got more than
one car
now yeah he's got the lease too you got
a leash but what's happening with the
other car
like the least i was gonna like i only
did the lease because i wanted to um
make cheap payments but like i was
planning to buy the car out at the end
of the lease i wanted to say yeah but
it's not it's not cheap payments because
you're gonna go over your miles
with all the travel you're doing you're
allotted miles in the lease and they're
gonna kill you with a mileage overage
read your contract
yeah i know okay and so the other car
where's the other car what's the deal
with the other car
well the other car right now um i'm
still paying for it but like i don't
really drive it i should go up the road
and stuff where is it in your driveway
yes okay what do you owe on it
uh 8800 okay what can you sell it for
like it sits
um i would say about like maybe 5 500
okay good go borrow three thousand
dollars and get that thing out of your
driveway
then you owe three thousand dollars
instead of eight thousand dollars and
then you owe ten thousand dollars so
it's thirteen thousand dollars and you
make sixty two thousand now we got a
plan baby we're gonna click this thing
off hold on we're going to have the team
pick up and sign you up for financial
peace university you do everything we
teach you to do in that class you'll be
debt-free in a year and you're going to
have an emergency fund in 18 months
we're going to change your life if
you'll go do exactly what we tell you to
do you can do this
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life your money
your mental health your relationships
your careers here on the ramsey show
it's tax season
and i know that's thrilling to most
people
uh
nope don't know anybody loves this uh if
filing your taxes does not have to be
horrible
we created ramsey smart tax to give you
software that you can actually trust
i'm not going to try to sell you some
more stuff or sell you debt or surprise
you with fees you didn't see coming
smart tax has steps that are simple and
clear you know you've done your taxes
right no more headaches second guessing
yourself
never tack on surprise fees never sell
your info to scummy companies trying to
get you into debt
not like the other people don't do all
of that
when you sign up for ramsey plus it's
even easier you can actually file your
federal taxes for free
don't get taken advantage of by your tax
software ever again start your free
trial of ramsey plus and ramsey plus
members get to use ramsey smart tax free
so free free free free free free trial
for ramsey plus get into get into
financial peace university in every
dollar oh and file your taxes with
ramsey smart tax and again ramsey plus
members get that free so that's pretty
cheap it's a pretty good deal all at
ramseysolutions.com
ramsayplus
ramseysolutions.com slash ramsey plus
kevin is i'm sorry deanna is with us in
san antonio texas hi deanna how are you
i'm doing well can you hear me okay
absolutely what's up
oh my gosh
my heart rate is like 121.
okay you're gonna be okay we've never
lost a patient
well it's it's nice being on the phone
with both of you yeah
okay my question is um
i'm still on baby step two but
my
uh term life is ending
this year
so last year i ended up getting
long-term health care
should i
should i not do that since i'm still on
baby step two how old are you
56 long-term care insurance i would not
buy until you're 60.
okay
long-term care insurance long-term care
insurance is nursing home insurance
right right probability of you spending
time in a nursing home before 60 years
old is .005
okay and the only reason i got that was
because i'm by myself
and i always thought well i don't want
any anybody to burn i don't want to burn
anybody
so i figured
to do that that would be nice when
you're 60.
okay
but this is like this is like buying
homeowners insurance and you don't have
a house
right and i have a house and i still owe
on it okay that's not what i'm talking
about
right i'm saying you bought insurance
that is not it is covering something
that has such a low probability of
happening at your age that i would not
buy it right
okay you need the money to do other
things what do you make a year
uh 48 okay and how much debt do you have
hon
like 29 on what
401k loan
a car
and
a
kitchen
renault okay
all right
and so
number one have you learned your lesson
that borrowing money is not going to
make you wealthy or happy
yes okay and how much do you owe on this
car
18
it's a lot
i know it is a lot okay here's the rule
of thumb i use on cars once we find
somebody in a car debt there's two
things we look at one can you be
debt-free
everything except your home in two years
you might but it's going to be tight
i i've been running the numbers because
i paid long term 167.
i can be
that that's a lot yeah it is
that's two thousand that's two thousand
dollars a year yeah
i know i i was looking at the house well
i'll call find out
i'll cancel it
but you owe twenty nine thousand and you
make forty eight thousand you could be
debt free in two years but it's gonna be
tight can you sell that car and most of
your debt is just car i'd sell it
well here's the worst part is that i
just got it like maybe
last year because i was in a wreck and
they totaled my perfectly paid car
that's okay
what's the car worth that you're driving
do you have any idea
um
[Music]
maybe
29
okay
yeah so here here's what i would do if i
woke up in your shoes you need to think
about this if you're gonna do it but
i've done this so many times in the last
30 years that it's easy for me to make
the decision so plus it's not my car so
you got to make the decision yourself
but if i woke up in your shoes i would
sell that car and get me a cash car that
i paid 9 000 for
ten thousand dollars for
and then that leaves you just nine
thousand dollars in debt you'll be debt
free by christmas
and then you're living on a budget and
you're going to rebuild your emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
and your life is good i mean think about
what it'd be like to have ten thousand
dollars in the bank and no payments at
all
i thought about that when i got in the
wreck and then i thought oh my gosh
it's like karma i don't know not karma
i'm not
i'm nervous
you're okay you hear what i'm saying
though what would it feel like breathe
that in what would it feel like to have
no payments
and ten thousand dollars in the bank
oh you feel great you could be there in
12 months doing what i'm talking about
and then that sets you up with a lot of
freedom
a lot of peace
a lot of mathematical margin to start to
build some wealth and retire with
dignity
yes
i agree that's what i want for you
and i want you to forgive yourself for
buying this car you're carrying a
direction hey everybody makes mistakes
it's okay yeah
i mean i i made so many mistakes i've
got a phd in dumb
so you know it's okay that's that's what
qualifies me to do this shows i've done
almost every dumb thing you people out
there have done that's how i recognize
it so quickly and it's also how i
cut stuff out of your life
like just like with a samurai sword
instantaneously i don't think it doesn't
bother me at all it's like
sell it car's gone sell it just cut it
out right there you know it's just done
and it's easy for me because i know
where you're gonna end up if you do this
stuff and you follow all the way through
and so the temporary pain
is worth it's worth the temporary pain
to get to the prize yeah at the end of
the story just going to sleep yeah not
owning anybody anything yeah and it's uh
it's a different thing man i mean
and uh you know you talk about all the
time how trauma rests in the body and
you know you get tight across your
shoulder blades and that kind of stuff
you know
when people do there's a physical change
in your body when you're when you don't
have any payments when your body
recognizes oh we're safe now yeah
hey you just it falls off of you it's
just like your shoulders drop yeah it's
just a
yeah so you can you can if you laugh
again what's interesting is i've done
this with like an audience with like
five or ten thousand people and i say
okay hey everybody just close your eyes
think how it would feel to have no
payments yeah
it's audible you can you can hear
this relax all through this 10 000
people it's audible you physically feel
the shift in the auditorium
it's crazy and that's that's how that's
what that's what we've done to ourselves
in this country we're just frenetic
we're so tight yeah we're frenetic
get the next thing
answer the next mean tweet man that's
right run run run run run fight fight
fight yeah and i don't have any real
friends i don't have any money and i'm
just
everything's just there's no margin
there's no peace there's no relaxation
one of my favorite things on this show
pissed off all the time all the time is
to watch the a debt-free screen and you
ask them how does it feel and they 100
their face changes their bodies changed
and and if it's a couple they like
cuddle in a little closer but when you
when you ask them hey what was it like
take us back to the beginning their body
goes back yeah they can remember it
remembers it yeah remember and then all
of a sudden the stuff you talk about on
your show all the time i think about it
we are free we're free yeah it's a
there's a physical change and so the
stress related
illnesses
have
too many times finances at their room oh
absolutely and decisions we've made on
our they put our put ourselves in that
and it just people were walking around
with one big ball of stress give
yourself yeah sell that car and then be
free go be free move on if that's the
dumbest thing you're ever doing you're
freaking you win you're a genius
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life your money
your
relationships your mental health your
job your career it's all right here on
the ramsay show
kevin is with us in dallas to start off
this hour hi kevin how are you
hey sir i'm doing great how are you
doing better than i deserve what's up
yes sir so um my question i had is my uh
my wife and i we are debt free we don't
have any payments or anything
and so we are currently um retiring or
we're currently trying to retire with 15
um being put away but we're wondering um
how much more we should be trying to do
can we get your house paid off too
yes sir oh then 15 doesn't apply that's
only until you get your house paid off
after your house is paid off you should
max out all your retirement options
because you should have plenty of money
left over after that so still have fun
okay she got 401k
um yes so my my wife has um 401k i have
one two um max on both and max out two
roth iras
so max out two ras and both of our rots
yep all in good growth stock mutual
funds
how much what's your household income
um so we bring in about um 160 between
my wife and i how old are you i'm
26. oh you're gonna be so rich it's
unbelievable grief kevin congratulations
paid off that early man way to go
thank you so so much really um i think
it was just because the way that my
parents raised uh raised my siblings and
i we i i had always been um kind of a
saver but we just got this little house
the
the
nicest
looking house on the street in a pretty
nice nice area of town and then just
kind of fix it up with my dad and i and
um got married just had a uh baby like a
few weeks ago so way to go man what's
this house what's this house worth
so currently um i think we're thinking
it's about 100k or so so
it's um not too bad for a starter homie
yeah kevin you've done a really really
good job of getting started here yeah i
would max out your retirement and then
i'd start saving some money on the side
in addition to that in a mutual fund to
move up in house and pay cash for the
move up
you've just done such a great job
getting started because you have no
payments in the world you make a lot of
money and a brand new baby man you just
got you got life by the tail well done
well done and high five to your dad and
mom man great job make sure you pass
this along to your little one too yeah
all right good for you this is legacy
change stuff right here well done
denisha's in austin texas hi denisha how
are you
hello
denisha hi
how are you hi i'm fine how are you
better than i deserve what's up
okay so i have a little
situation um
anytime somebody starts a call with okay
and have a situation it's gonna be great
go for it
okay so
i
uh just um
i had a lot of credit card debt a lot of
it
and i'm in
school and i just got a new job very
very proud of my job because
uh
going to school for accounting i've been
presented a lot of opportunities and
it's been really great for me so i'm
pretty happy what are you calling about
that you didn't call about that
i'm sorry
about that you're avoiding it yeah what
is it my
my spouse is very upset with me why
would you i just got my check
i just got my tax return and i paid off
all the credit cards
and why is he upset that you're debt
free
because
we're broke
and he
said hey we can just pay the minimums so
why in the world would you just pay the
pay the whole thing that way because we
don't have a lot of money so he's like
you just use all of our tax return to
pay all the credit i get
okay
how long you guys been married
uh seven years how old are you
30. okay does he work
he's disabled he's fully disabled okay
what's the nature of his disability uh
bilateral apg
okay
wow all right
and so he has disability income is all
he has coming in yes sir okay all right
so the problem is not that you paid off
the credit card debt or that you didn't
pay off the credit card debt the problem
is is that the two of you are not
working together
yes sir
and so you should never he should never
be surprised by a money move you make
because you should have both decided the
money moved together you actually did
the right thing in the wrong way
yes sir
that makes sense
it does make sense so his his opinion is
wrong his anger is right
yes sir that makes sense
yes sir why'd you feel like you had to
go behind his back
did you know what he was gonna say
i knew he was gonna say that we
shouldn't have done it because he said
we can just pay the minimums that's all
they asked for and i said but we're
trying to get a house we're in my dad's
house he wants us out
not because he doesn't like us here but
he's because he wants you to be
self-sustaining and have dignity
correct so i'm trying to get us to that
point
and so that's why you know
it's hard huh
marriage is hard y'all struggling
we're really stressed i'm so sorry we
have a disabled child
who is in and out of the hospital as
well
so
she's
our blessing but she's it's just hard in
that way too so so i've walked i've
walked alongside folks in your situation
tell me if i'm if i'm on the money or if
i'm missing the boat here
that in many ways you are both a wife
and a mother you run the household
except when
um
your disabled husband leans up and says
well i want to be a part of this
decision so you're responsible for
everything you need to be out running
doing everything except when i want to
weigh in is that is that fair
that's absolutely correct so you carry
everything including the quote unquote
bad decisions that you made on your own
which are supposed to be right so here's
what i really want you to do would your
husband go talk to a marriage counselor
with you
i don't know i don't know if he thinks
that we have a problem
okay that tells me that you're not being
honest with him and i know that i don't
want to dump it all on you because you
may not be safe to be honest but you got
to because here's what i'm afraid is
going to happen you're going to get a
new job and you're going to make great
money and you're going to go meet
co-workers who are going to light you up
they're going to love you and they're
going to fill gaps in your relationships
in relation to needs that you have
that your husband hasn't been doing or
that y'all have gotten so far apart and
what's going to happen is you're going
to make some you're gonna what you just
did going behind his back is gonna get
worse and worse and worse and worse and
worse
and so i want you to find a place where
we can start having open and direct
conversations because like dave said you
did the right thing with the money he
did it the wrong way and i don't want
this to you to look up five years from
now and your family's falling apart yeah
his opinion was wrong
but his right to be in on the decision
was right yeah so the two of you need to
start making all the decisions together
all the time
and you need some practice at that you
don't have the muscles to do that so you
need to get with a good marriage
counselor to help you develop that
and yeah you do have a problem
you have a lot of problems and you need
to work on them get right in the middle
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you that's why you need to get in touch
with churchill mortgage to make sure you
do this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five jason wichita kansas
hi jay how are you
i'm good thanks for taking my call sure
what's up i'm
i'm 36 and my wife's 35
she's a school teacher and i'm a farmer
we've got our house and our vehicles
paid for my equipment's paid for all
right um
yeah but we do we did buy a farm a
quarter ground here a couple years ago
and we owe about 180 000 on it
um
my dilemma is i've got three kids i've
got a six-year-old boy a three-year-old
boy and a one-year-old daughter and my
wife is pregnant with twins
so we're uh we're out of room in our
house
and i've had several contractors come
out to look at being an addition and
they're all i mean it's 180 000 to do
that
so i'm looking for advice
your house is on your farm
well we bought a quarter of ground no we
own the house but we live very very
rural
but yeah we did buy a quarter ground for
uh when we owe 180 on that but the house
is paid for no i'm sorry it's the house
is your house on
your farm no no sir
okay so your house is in a subdivision
or it's a simple city lot or what
no we live a long ways from town i mean
we're out in the middle of nowhere okay
how much acreage is around the home
uh about five acres you own five acres
in a house okay
because it's a lot easier to move
but even i mean even if we were open to
that there's there's nowhere to move
around here i mean the closest town to
us has 300 people and there's nothing
for sale and it's just it's not an
option and you know this whole house
we've done so much to uh we kind of feel
like we need to keep moving forward well
i don't um because you're you're
building another house is what you're
doing
oh yeah pretty much yeah
i mean this is basically a you know you
and i'm not sure you're going to end up
with anything you're going to like when
all this is done it's very difficult to
do a remodel that doubles the size of a
house and not end up with a pretzel
yeah
well yeah like i said we've had several
people come out and look and i'm
comfortable with them i'm just
uncomfortable with a paid for house and
then you know spending that much but
like i said they're moving moving
there's nowhere to move i mean that's
that's really not an option
we do need more room
okay anytime somebody tells me it's
really not an option uh my ears perk up
because what you're doing is you're
backing yourself into a corner to
justify a decision you're about to make
that you don't feel comfortable with i
kind of think it might be
easier to buy a five-acre track down the
road and build a house
but wouldn't that cost i mean wouldn't
that cost double what we're doing
well i mean you're gonna sell the one
you're in
well i mean i guess but i mean i've got
my shop i work out of i've got a heated
shop and another building and all that
stuff that i you know i need to work on
equipment over the winter
so build a shop
on the new property where you build a
new house
i mean you can do 180 000
edition if you want to do one i mean
there's nothing keeping you from doing
it
so i'm not really sure what your
question is because you i think you've
already decided you're going to do it so
i guess you're just gonna do it yeah i
mean
the only other way i know to do it is to
maybe end up with a better property when
it's all said and done that was new from
the ground up rather than a piece
together
house because i'm just telling you man
when you add on an add-on and add-on it
is very difficult to create a
practical property that is not
impossible to get rid of later because
you you designed this weird thing
that you're 180 000 on the old house
stuck on the side of it so very hard to
do let me ask you like so let me make
sure i'm i'm clear here let's say
his current house is worth 120 i'm
trying to do easy math
so he would sell it for
120 go build a 300 000 new house with a
shop with a shop so we're less talking
about dollars and cents here and more
you're gonna end up with a wonky donkey
house that you can't sell
because yeah if you're not careful you
will i mean it can be done but it's very
difficult it's a lot easier just to
build absolutely just start over yeah
yeah
so while people do tear downs instead of
renaults and i got a hint that he really
like they've put up some some sweat
equity in this house and so we are
forced to stay here and that's why i'm
impressed
you're not forced to stay anywhere right
there's nothing there's nothing holding
you there except your emotions right and
so um you need to really decide you know
and and if you keep a house because you
have a heated shop that was a dumb idea
yeah because you can build a heated shop
that's that's a cheap ad that's not
that's not an expensive ad the expensive
ads all these bedrooms and baths for all
these kids
so um
but if you want to if you want to do the
180 000 renovation you can do that too
but you're going to be back in debt and
you've got a mortgage and you're gonna
have to pay the mortgage off then and
you put it on 15 year or less it's more
no more than a fourth of your take-home
pay and you get it paid off as fast as
you can
it's very difficult to do emotionally to
go back into debt but you're going to go
back into debt either way if you're
going to have a house because apparently
you know you've got a huge family now
and a tiny house and so you're gonna
you're going to make a move some way or
another to get a place to put all these
kids yeah
so um i'd rather get what you want for
for the money yeah i think you'll end up
with a cleaner deal by making a move but
if you don't do the renovation to the
renovation just be careful that you do
it
with a lot of planning
and really think through
you know because i've been in houses
where you have to walk through one
bedroom to get to the other absolutely
you know and this is just it's just poor
design that's what it amounts to and
it's just weird
and um you know the old saying and it's
not because he's calling from a country
thing but the old thing is you build it
like a country house you just keep
adding on rooms and
and you know instead of beginning with
the end in mind right with a blueprint
from the top down and you just there's a
room over there and then there's a room
over there and then there's a room now
there's an audition over there and it
just that's a
that's a classic saying and there's a
reason it's a proverb
uh pat's in minneapolis hi pat how are
you
hi dave how you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
that's good i've got a question for you
you i heard an ad for the on your show
just now about the term life insurance
how we should get it until you
build a certain amount of wealth
at what point what what what level of
wealth are we talking about
when can i get rid of buying life
insurance
well self-insured
the definition of being self-insured for
life insurance purposes is if you die
does your wife have enough money and
investments left
to take care of life
and not have a substantial change in her
situation
and so
you know uh
usually that means you've got everything
paid off the kids are grown and gone
and you know you got
half a million to three million dollars
in your mutual funds or something like
that that's usually what it means but
you can just start asking yourself the
question
if you died how old are you
uh 52 and what's your net worth my
weight 53. uh we have uh
3.1 in an asset okay any other income
producing do they make money
no it's just uh
roth ira so it's all in retirement at
home
yeah it's all retirement okay so if you
died between now and 59 and a half she
would have some of that as an inherited
ira that she could access
and she'd be fine
well she's she's the one making the
money okay well
then if she dies would you be okay yes
i think you guys can live off of the
income created by three million dollars
or two million hotels of two million on
each other you don't need it
what's that you don't need it
that's what i'm wondering yeah and she's
she earns uh
our combined girl well she earns 330
right now the way you could the way you
could determine this is to say
if she passed away
could i use some of those mutual funds
and the income off of them to live a
very nice life
and the answer is yes you could
yeah without any insurance
okay and if you died could she
with her income
yeah she can make it with her income if
she didn't even have any mutual funds
and she's still got the same mutual
funds to work for
okay
all
right do you mind if i ask you one more
quick question uh if it's super quick
yeah running up to the clock go quick
okay uh we have like 290 on our house
and i only have about 110 in savings for
i'd dig up some money and get that
sucker paid off that's the answer to
your question pay it off
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five tracy's with us in
seattle hi tracy welcome to the ramsay
show
hi grace hi dr dr john
hey what's up i've got a question i've
got a question for you my husband and i
are having a bit of an arm wrestle about
death
um in may i turned 62
in september my husband turned 65
and in 128 days loose county i retire
so
i am like so excited i'm spitting
bubbles
um
what i want to know we want to know is
when can we start drawing social
security
what we're living on now is his his
pension and my paycheck
which net is about 55.50 a month
and then november in august i'll get my
first uh retirement pension which will
be gross
about 3 100
and then after taxes and
my my employee contribution for my
retiree health and his
supplemental insurance
will come out of my
pension check
so
starting like august or september
in september
his net pension is like 22.50
my gross
pension is about 3100
so i'm and i'm not sure what the
net going to be on that
so when should we start and we're not
drawing anything from
his pen or his 401k
or other
retirement resources we've got how much
is in your mistakes
um
total net worth between our house which
is paid off
here's 401k my deferred comp
savings etc we're right between probably
2.9 and 3.1 way to go
you've done such a great job
congratulations how much of this how
much of this did you inherit
um
just
less than a year ago
i inherited
about three hundred thousand so you were
already we were already millionaires we
were worth about
between 2.6 and 2.7 when my mom passed
away yeah wow
you've done so well congratulations very
well done
so the bottom line answer is this
it doesn't matter
social security doesn't mean beans to
you
you got three million dollars
you can do whatever you want to do
it doesn't matter
now if you want to do it if you want to
have a math discussion just for the
theory of it and the fun of it
social security dies when you die
and it's a negative rate of return the
money you put into social security you
will never get all of it out
right so you might as well get all you
can get as fast as you can get
so i take it early and often
and just throw it into an investment if
you don't need it
yeah and the crazy thing to add into the
mix my husband's thinking of
going back and getting a job
you know and it's like we don't we don't
need him to be working and here i am on
the verge of retiring
no none of this matters yeah here's the
thing social security little bitty
amount of money three million dollars a
lot of money
your whole yeah your whole life is
governed by the fact that you have the
returns on three million dollars to live
out the rest of your life in style with
incredible generosity and with
incredible enjoyment and
if you'd never got a social security
check ever
it wouldn't affect this discussion
if you get one it doesn't affect this
discussion
it's a mathematical
discussion is all it is it's just like a
little math riddle is all it is but it's
it really does not affect your life
because of how great a job you've done
building wealth you did what you're
supposed to do you didn't depend on
social insecurity thank god it's not
fifty percent of your income or seventy
percent of your income it's one percent
or less than one percent of your income
because your income should be three four
hundred thousand dollars a year
off of this off of these returns on
these investments you know and so 200
300 000 a year and we're talking about
you know social security's going to be
nothing it's nothing so
it's a freaking joke which is what it's
always been and by the way
a lot of people retire
and then a few months later say i'm
gonna go get a part-time job or i'm
gonna go back and do
something
it's not always because i need the money
in fact it's often not because i need
the money it's because i miss the social
engagement i miss the purpose i miss
doing something that i love the reason
to get out of bed in the morning so i
wouldn't knock on that if he wants to go
back to work um i'd have a broader
conversation about what y'all's life is
gonna look like together when you retire
in exactly 128 days right yeah isn't
that fun that's fun you've done such a
great job
well done well done so i would take it i
would take it all as quickly as i can
get it but it doesn't matter
so i'm not going to have a big arm
wrestle over it it doesn't matter
thank god the reason it doesn't matter
is because you built wealth i think we
can all tell that in an armoredly match
she would win
[Laughter]
rachel's in st louis hi rachel how are
you
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure um i just have a quick
question um my husband and i were in our
mid-50s our kids our three kids are out
of the house the only debt we do have
currently is is our house we owe 130 on
that
we have 180 in savings 35 in our
checking so basically about 210
and about 400 in retirement why have you
not paid off your house
well
we're getting there i'm he's coming
around why were you worried why you have
to get there why don't you just do it
i that's what that's what i'm wanting to
do because i know that's what what you
always advise well the reason i would
advise it is it's smart
yeah why does your husband not want to
pay off the house
our financial advisor was telling us
she's encouraging us to take that 130.
and put it with him or he can make a
commission yes of course yeah she would
say now it's the time to buy okay
yes new time new financial advisor time
they do not have your best interest
they're trying to pad their portfolio
i gotcha okay
because he's a my husband is the main
breadwinner i i teach preschool so mine
supplemental he has a base salary of 75
plus bonuses so he can average about 140
that 175 depending
uh how does that matter in this
discussion pay your house off
today okay have a party congratulations
you're dead or you're your opinion is
not invalid because you teach preschool
it actually makes your attention opinion
more valuable
okay because you put up with small
humans that are crazy
all day and their parents which are
worse
yeah
i think because the just that security
of thinking you have that and i mean you
want security have a paid for house
nobody can ever take it from you ever
ever ever ever it's yours yeah
okay
listen here's the thing here's the thing
if you fire your financial advisor and
get one that actually is doesn't have
that has your best interests at heart
and you pay off your house
and you just discover that it's a
horrible experience you can go get you a
mortgage
okay
go take 130 000 yeah uh
home improvement loan and invest that
money
there you go an equity loan this is how
that works yeah yeah immediately don't
pass go so um yeah
and here's the thing we're probably
exaggerating a little bit
possibly that the financial advisor is
not just trying to pad the portfolio
he's probably one of these fools that
actually believes
that you should stay in debt on your
house because you can invest and make
more money they're looking at they're
saying i can earn you ten percent and
your your your apr's is three percent
why would you do that and they left out
common sense and risk
and they left out the toll
on your relationships the toll on your
body the toll
on
when there's a pandemic i'm looking over
my shoulder you know paid for house
you it's one of the building blocks of
wealth in all the data that we have from
real millionaires not financial advisors
with an opinion right but from real
millionaires pay your household they pay
off their house and they build their 401
occasion retirement that's what they do
all the data says that
and so
he he might not be uh
just trying to rip you off he might just
be dumb but either one's dangerous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you